the coronavirus pandemic has derailed
the tokyo 2020 olympics
the biggest sporting event in the world
but covert 19
isn't the only threat facing global
sport
the olympics has been dogged by scandals
over doping
race relations and the inclusion of
intersex and transgender athletes
edwin moses is an olympic hero who
dominated the men's 400 meter hurdles
for a decade up to his retirement in
1989
he broke the world record on four
separate occasions
since then he's been chair of the u.s
anti-doping agency
and is now chair of the laurius sport
for good foundation
edwin moses welcome to the economist
asks thank you
thank you i'm very glad to be here this
week we
should see the start of the olympic
games instead
we're talking from both of our homes of
course as it's been postponed
can you imagine how that feels for
an athlete like yourself who put so much
into these
key moments i know exactly how it feels
from
uh what happened in uh the 1980 olympic
games in moscow when the united states
olympic team and several other olympic
teams from around the world didn't get
to compete
the only difference this time is that as
we know right now
it's only been postponed so the athletes
are are hoping that they may be able to
compete
but uh you know it's uh something that
really
really guts you i see that a member of
the japanese olympic organizing
committee
has said actually just before we started
recording that unless coronavirus
conditions
improved a lot the tokyo games already
postponed wouldn't be
able to go ahead in 2021 and it
if they don't what do you think the
impact will be on the sporting world
even if things were perfect in tokyo and
or china in 2022
i just don't see how you can safely
bring that many people together from
various points in the world under the
conditions that we have now
and how did you prepare physically and
mentally for
olympic races take us back if you could
to the first time so that's montreal in
1976 before that
for many missing olympics of the 1980s
because there was a
protest against the soviet occupation of
afghanistan
but 76 there you are on the starting
line and unknown i think
at the time headed for gold what took
you there
my story is very unusual in that i went
to college on a
academic scholarship to study physics
and engineering
the small college that i went to
morehouse college which is the
alma mater of dr martin luther king i
went to school with his son
and some of my classmates spike lee and
samuel jackson were there at the time
it was well we didn't have any facility
we didn't have a track we didn't have a
field so i
literally was jumping fences all of 1974
75 and 76 and i had the opportunity to
go to
and qualifying for those olympic trials
uh almost exactly four months to the day
before the olympics
and um i had to pick one of those events
i
fortunately i picked the right event the
toughest one the 400 hurdles
and uh four months later i was olympic
champion so when i got there i felt like
i was a gladiator uh with the mission
because i should have never been there
in the first place and i knew that i was
prepared
i knew that i was going to win a world
record and i did
i'm just going to move us perhaps along
to
the broader application of sport or
meaningful sport
for you in the world and and since you
left competitive
athletics i know it's the motto of your
glorious foundation that sport
has the power to change the world and if
we look back from
john carlos and tommy smith and the
famous black power salute in
1968 to peter connor
waving the irish flag at the beginning
of the 20th century sports have
often been used as a platform for
protest do you think that
you have to think very carefully about
what you protest about or do you think
really it's up to the conscience of each
and every athlete
with a limelight on them if they're at a
high level as you describe
to to choose what they do i think it's
up to the athlete
uh you know i talked with tommy smith
and john carlos
uh they both live here in atlanta
they're both really good friends of mine
and uh you know before they protested in
uh in mexico city
the whole thing was is that they've got
to go round by round they've got to get
to the final
and then they've got to get on the
podium so i think the protest part of it
is not anything that athletes
go in thinking well i'm going to win a
gold medal or silver and then i'm going
to protest about this i don't think
athletes do that i think it's something
that happens organically
i just had this argument for a very long
time my father who also helped
to train me was very involved with
athletics and with the local stadium and
he was very much of a view
the politic the more politics was
threaded through sport the more
it sort of undermined the sort of purity
of the
the sport and that you should really
leave your views
behind you in other than very extreme
circumstances
what do you think can you ever or should
you ever take politics out of sport
in many cases you have people that that
say athletes ought to shut up
but only if you don't only if i don't
agree with you if i agree with you then
it's okay
and so that's one of the the big issues
with it but
uh sports people are like any other
profession we have the right to
to to to think about and talk about and
express
what we feel uh same thing as a doctor
or lawyer or teacher everyone
in most parts of the world not all parts
of the world but we do have that
that opportunity to express our rights
and i i think that there's no way
that at an olympic games you're gonna
contain athletes especially in the
environment
that we're all we are in right now where
there's you know
uh protests on racism for example all
over the world there's pro
people that want to protest about having
clean water
about disease and what's going to happen
to disease
uh about refugees in certain parts of
the world and war
and and land mines and people uh
being gassed and gassed in their in
their country so there's there's plenty
of reasons that athletes need to be
concerned
yes i was going to give a flavor of that
with this
broadening out of gestures of solidarity
if we look for instances of american
basketball the women's nba will have
black lives matter
on their training jerseys the nba will
have the motto stenciled onto the court
for the new season i'd just like to ask
you how much power you feel
that these gestures have
i get the impression that you largely
support
protest wouldn't you feel that people
should protest if they wish to
but how powerful are they in actually
bringing about change as opposed to
being
totemic in some way i was looking at
instagram one
one evening and there was a 14 year old
girl that was at one of the protests and
she had a sign
that uh george floyd is not a wake-up
call
we've had it on snooze for for for too
long and i think that's true
so over here people have really been
inundated
and had a chance to see an experience
and see visually and understand you know
the plight of what's been going on
i had another friend of mine one of my
jewish high school
our friends were still friends today she
said being
being not being a racist is not enough
you have to be
anti-racist people have begun to think
about it not only in the united states
but all over america
and uh and be educated about the plight
of african-american people in the
history of slavery the history of
confederacy uh and and be able to see
what their own eyes what
police brutality looks like and and see
the statistics and see the
uh the disparity you went to the mainly
black
college you spent your time in athletics
so obviously
mixed worlds there racially but at the
time
a lot was really not changing in in
society
we think that society has changed and
yet a lot of
your colleagues i think others who have
made protest gestures have said
that it didn't change i think tommy
smith and john carlos actually
among this number that it didn't change
as much as they thought
what's your personal experience been
well it it definitely has changed
um it's changed in ways there's been
significant changes like the voting
rights act
uh night brown versus edu brown versus
the board of education all those things
made significant changes but in the last
20 years
and and even in the last three to five
years a lot of that has been rolled back
by the supreme court
there's significant changes a young kid
if i was 20 years old
and growing up today i'd have three
four five hundred percent more
opportunities than than i would have
when i was growing up i could work for
an investment bank i could i could be a
ceo for a university
a top level accountant i could be a ceo
of a major fortune 500 company
those things weren't possible 40 years
ago so there's been a significant change
in opportunity
uh that is there to be had but at the
core of it
um the the the the insensitivity to
to the what's happening to native
americans and african african-american
people
and even poor white people you know
they've been beat up for a long time too
and it has nothing to do with the color
of the skin all the time in many cases
it's straight economics so it's it's a
class
struggle it's not necessarily all about
black and white and hopefully people
don't get that
uh confused uh because when that happens
there's a lot of people over here that
are white that actually vote against
against their best interests because
they get caught up on on the racial
thing and they've been taught
uh to hate and talk to to not care and
have empathy for
people who perhaps may not look like
them but have exactly the same issues
uh the racial issue has been used to
divide americans
in many ways that are very insidious and
subliminally
applied at a different uh different
angle now what you've
been doing and that's the anti-doping
agency which you you have
moved on to to chair you made your views
clear quite early on and really from
about 1988 onwards that you felt
athletics was
moved in the wrong direction and needed
a corrective since there we've been to
and
fro with various doping scandals as the
tests have become more sophisticated it
might seem so have the
drugs what are your pressing concerns
now who is winning this cat and mouse
the problem that we are needing to deal
with
as quickly as possible that has been
going on for the last six years is the
problem
of russia anti-doping over there in
russia means just don't get caught
uh before you go to a world
championships well we want to detect you
at home
before you go so that you won't get
caught when you leave the country
um it's uh it's it's uh their their
their anti-doping programs are really
designed to assist
athletes to use uh substances undetected
very unlike uh in the uk and in the
united states is your argument
fundamentally that
america and largely the west dealt with
its doping problem and the russians
didn't
no it's it's all over the world in fact
when i was um
running a lot of our athletes were
really good pals and buddies with the
russians and these germans and they
discussed and compared and talked about
what substances they were using
because they actually felt that well
you're gonna do it so i'm gonna do it
too at least
you know let's take the same drugs and
and uh
and and compete and hope that we don't
get caught i just fundamentally disagree
with with
with uh that philosophy and that's one
of the reasons i got i got in the drug
uh
anti-doping business i think we're
winning and and lots of countries around
the world where they
unabated use of some of the most
powerful and common drugs can't occur
anymore so they're looking at a whole
different
uh way of doing testing this is much
more effective
so we're able to root out or drugs that
everyone has been using all the time
those can be found effectively but
there's other stuff
out there and there always will be
something that um
didn't arise as a debate in your earlier
days but is now
very much in the spotlight the ioc ruled
in march it would wait till after the
tokyo games to rule on how sports
organizations
would deal with a delicate question of
transgender intersex and
athletes whose biology might be seen as
giving them
some unfair advantage what is your view
of this it's very very complicated um
i was really disappointed uh initially
in the way that
castor symmania was treated by the
international amateur athletic
federation i just thought it was wrong
so so just to clarify for our our list
this catastrophe is an athlete who's
hyper androgynous and the initial ruling
against was she should adjust or reduce
her natural testosterone to compete
as a woman is that the way you'd
understand it yeah but
you know when you use words like
androgynous and and and
uh sex intersex there's a wide
range of different levels of intersex
and hormonal um anomalies
i would call it that but uh the the the
case
really stood on whether or not she was a
biological male
uh versus a woman with a lot of
testosterone
and so she fell outside of that category
from
the research that i've seen of being
just a woman with a lot of testosterone
and in fact
was a biological male who had lived a
life
as a woman uh and through no thought of
her own was was very very good in track
and field so it you know it's a case
that uh
it's quite emotional you know for me and
everyone else
uh i guess the question would be and
unfortunately i don't have a daughter
but would you want your daughter to be
running against uh
generally a man uh who's
uh a transgender but yet still
has a biological uh makeup that
is very very different from most women
way outside of the range so it's it's
difficult
i've i don't know what i would have done
if i had to make a decision
it does seem to be like you think she
she ought to be competing
against male athletes she has a distinct
advantage over female athletes
she's producing testosterone from some
of the charts that i've seen
or or some of the cases that are very
very similar to hers that are well
into what the average man produces
you've said that you think the sport has
its head in the ground
on this issue and i think you reflect it
because you pick your way through it it
is it is very it's morally complex it's
complex in terms of the sport and indeed
definitions
but what would it mean for the sport to
to take its head
off the ground you know to face up to it
what would that entail
i think it was last year or the year
before they finally
made a decision and decided that
these athletes would have to have lower
testosterone levels either by
medication or not uh either don't
compete
who have medications to temper the
testosterone
i think that um uh that
that presents a dilemma as well um
but at the same time we have we have
limits we have
categories for men and women based
specifically on sex so it's not like
you're discriminated against anyone
uh why don't women compete with men
because there's a distinct advantage
that men have because we produce more
testosterone
that is the fundamental uh position
of all sports in this world that you
have to recognize that there is a
difference
and dr moos has given this 30 years
since i saw you run
even if you didn't see me though i think
you're in my little
little autograph book here somewhere in
this
great panoply of of names from from
athletics he's that stood the test of
30 years when i've lost everything else
so i was wondering
if you were to take me running in london
i hope you'll take up my challenge and i
think you know i think you might just
about to
keep up but what are your tips for
improvement for those of us who have a
lot of our listeners who will be very
amateur athletes
still kind of daydreaming of gold and if
not
gold but just at least of getting a good
deal better
give us your magic nostrum if you could
i think a lot of it is not just the
physical part but i think it's
mentally how you position yourself in
life
and what kind of uh person you're going
to be
i think in a lot of cases you're not
going to be a better athlete
you're not going to be much a much more
better athlete than the type of person
that you
are it's about personal development and
if you're able to
to develop yourself academically or in
your job
or or or just be more receptive to
information because you're willing to
work hard in sports i think those are
the benefits
uh that everyone can get from sports it
has nothing to do with how
fast you are or or or what to what level
you go
those are life skills that can go a long
way
dr edward moses thank you very much for
joining us
and thank you very much this interview
is from our show
the economist asks and every week we
publish a new episode
in which we interview key figures in
world events
the link opposite will take you to a
page with all of our previous episodes
thanks for watching